on this holiday weekend A lot of people
will probably be out barbecuing or
swimming but the true meaning of
Memorial Day was not lost on a few who
woke up early today to plant thousands
of American flags 8 news now reporter
Joshua paguero was at today's flanking
ceremony
organizers say at least 500 volunteers
came to the cemetery to plant more than
30 thousand Flags honoring those
Americans who paid the ultimate
sacrifice every race color and age was
at the southern Nevada Veterans Memorial
Cemetery each holding the Star-Spangled
Banner they carefully stuck a flag near
a grave what it says to me is just to
always care for the people who served
Mark Wayman brought along his 10 year
old son hoping he learns a valuable
lesson Freedom isn't just something we
get but it's something that had to be
earned and that he sees the people that
actually earned it for us for some of
the children taking part in this
American ritual they understood what it
meant in the world is really just
representing and showing that we care
for those who have fallen died in wars
Jonathan Stone a U.S Navy veteran comes
from a family of veterans his dad and
uncle served in World War II we have to
respect I think respect is the most
important thing Christina arcos's father
is a veteran with her 12 year old
daughter in tow she says walking by each
grave is emotionally stirring and adds a
gravity to the sacrifice of protecting
our freedoms it's definitely emotional
and humbling to think of all these what
they say 33 000 people have been buried
here so you know coming and honoring
them letting them know that they're not
forgotten these American flags will stay
on the graves until Tuesday but there
will be an event on Monday honoring
those who pay the ultimate sacrifice
reporting at the southern Nevada
Veterans Memorial Cemetery Joshua
piguero eight news now Nevada's
Department of Veterans Services is
hosting that Memorial Day event on
Monday it starts at one at the southern
Veterans Memorial Cemetery in Boulder
City